during that biden campaign uh he claimed
that he would fight for
uh the middle class americans but
obviously
that's not happening it's time to
rebuild the backbone of this country
the middle class and this time bring
everybody along i see the world from
scranton
i see this world from working class
towns
i'm running as a proud democrat but i
will govern as an american president
you know reports though indicate that
the executive orders joe may sign his
first days in office show
just how little he cared about the
people who voted for him
and that's the sad part and he wants to
rejoin the paris climate accord on top
of it
scrapped the keystone xl pipeline and
he's signaling to iran that he'll
re-enter the disastrous nuclear deal
even as they throw
a u.s businessman in jail joining me now
to talk about this
is new york congressman lee zeldin uh
congressman good to have you here
tonight now
biden is really making clear his disdain
for
america first is he not
you see it with the the keystone xl
pipeline project
this is something that doesn't just kill
tens of thousands of jobs
it harms our efforts to be energy
independent there's the
national security concern where we have
to rely on
other countries that don't like us that
we view as adversaries
in order to pursue this resource the
paris climate
deal one of the issues was that nations
like
china didn't have to make big
concessions in order to
enter the deal put aside the fact this
is a treaty that was never presented to
the senate for the ratification
and of course as you mentioned the iran
nuclear deal iran being the world's
largest state sponsor of terror
and a joe biden administration is
looking to
trip over itself to re-enter the deal as
is despite all the practical
ramifications
of the fact that this deal is almost
done anyway with the sunset provisions
so a lot of national security concerns
with countries that i view as our
adversaries
okay and you know what congressman here
are more of biden's proposal for
his first hundred days rejoin the world
health organization
organize a climate world summit repeal
the 2017
tax cuts repeal liability protection for
gun manufacturers
congressman i ask again how is this
going to make americans lives any better
yeah these were campaign promises that
unfortunately didn't get
appropriately vetted out during the
campaign uh
when you were talking about
when he and his campaign were discussing
the idea of
reversing the 2017 tax cuts uh
well what what does that mean exactly
reverse all of it
or are only all you only plan on
reversing part of it
and as they were getting called out on
the fact that ultimately that would mean
a lot of people
end up with a tax increase then they
tried to word smith their answers as
they were getting called out on it
but you know what joe biden basically
every morning would get away
with calling a lid on his day at 7 or 8
a.m
the media was really in the tank for him
so they were okay with the fact that
they weren't able to ask uh the tough
questions that weren't the
accountability because they wanted to
get donald trump out of office
the first example you gave the world
health organization this time
last year the world health organization
was lying to the united states and the
rest of the world
about what was going on with coronavirus
they were lying that there was
no no evidence whatsoever of
human human transmission parroting ccp
talking points
so as you go down that list starting at
the beginning with the keystone xl
pipeline paris climate deal iran nuclear
deal
world health organization to the other
examples that you gave
he might have gotten himself elected to
this presidency
uh he might be taking the oath on
wednesday but this is going to result in
harm
to our economy to job growth to national
security and
energy independence and far more now is
a time for even
those in the media who helped him get
into this position
for them to start asking tough questions
too because a lot of people
get hurt and our country's gonna get
hurt
well clearly and you know the more he
preaches unity the top democrats are
sending a decidedly different message
and that's a that's a sad commentary on
where we are right now
thank you very much congressman lee
zeldin